بعد ان دخل البجات الفرنسي العام الماضي
ضمن قائمه التراث العالمي اصبحت المخابز
الفرنسيه هذا العام تعاني بشكل كبير بسبب
ازمه الطاقه ما يجعل هذا القطار في مازق
حقيقيا يهدد وجوده في حال ان تستطع الدوله
ايجاد حل مقنع لدعمه
لم يحمل العام الجديد الخير لاصحاب
المخابز في فرنسا بسبب ازمه الطاقه
المستمره فمع بدايه الشهر الاول من السنه
تبين انه يتوجب عليهم دفع فاتوره كهرباء
باهظه الثمن كصاحب هذا المخبز الذي تجاوزت
فاتورته الاخيره
12000 يورو بعدما كان يدفع 1800 يورو
شهريا في السابق قبل الازمه هذه الصدمه
جعلته يخرج عن صمته ويطالب الحكومه
بالتحرك
كثيرا كما ان فواتير الكهربائي ارتفعت
فجاه والحكومه اعلنت عن اجراءات لدعمنا
لكنها غير كافيه فما زال الجزء الاكبر
علينا دفعه وكل ما كانت الفاتوره كبيره
كلما صعوبه تسديدها
السكان هنا ايضا غاضبون ويشعلون بالخوف من
ان تؤدي هذه الازمه الى اخلاق المخبز
الوحيد في قريتهم
اننا نوافقه تماما لانه من غير المقبول
الا تقوم الدوله بفعل شيء لقد اصبحنا
رهائل فليس المخبز فقط من يدفع الثمن بل
نحن ايضا من جانبها اعلنت الحكومه عن
مساعده هذا القطاع من خلال تاجيل الضرائب
واشتراكات الضمان الاجتماعي للخبازين في
ما وجه الرئيس الفرنسي كلمه لموريده
الطاقه حقهم فيها على مساعده المخابز
والشركات الصغيره زينه عادي العربيه باريس